[Music]
okay so a serious health topic that
we've just been discussing we've
actually debated about it a couple times
and i really want to just kind of get
down to the facts because now
we've received some new information
tyson fury claims his success is down to
masturbating seven times a day what the
[ __ ]
seven
times that guy's a big man he's six
seven i would imagine maybe maybe he
masturbates but he doesn't ejaculate
oh
technicalities in the wording that's
true wait
if he's like just
gaining energy
and not like letting go [ __ ]
dick yeah he's tantric [ __ ] do we
know do we know he's dragon ball i want
to fantasize about that idea a little
bit longer as if it does like propel
power you know what i mean you're like
oh and then right when you stop you're
like suddenly just jacked up and can do
a lot you know what i'll i'll be honest
sometimes i sometimes i don't like i
don't come just because i know that if i
do i'm gonna be i'm gonna be [ __ ] i'm
gonna be tired for a little bit
so you go you go into it sometimes i'll
go into a session and then i'll be like
you know what [ __ ] it i gotta do [ __ ]
i don't stop
how many minutes you sound conflicted
[Laughter]
no it's not that it's just literally
like
i'm gonna be tired
so but you say that in the middle while
you're going
or before and you you go how do you do a
little bit how do you do the mental you
turn that it's also like right right
before you come and then you could stop
so you just start thinking of your youth
pastor or something like practice that
too okay
but
after effects genuinely though just not
tired because i feel like that's like um
trying to just delete the negative
versus okay
usually like usually two minutes comes
out of his trailer all jacked
usually two minutes later i'll just
[ __ ] ejaculate and come you know
ten
is here
again huh
the heavyweight champion has been
speaking ahead of his upcoming title
defense against dylan white which will
be taking place on april 23rd aka this
is an ad for that apparently the gypsy
king semi jokingly believes that
masturbation gives him the required
power in his hands to knock out his
opponent
by loading up on testosterone
scientifically makes sense do you load
more testosterone for
expending your body that's why i said
there's a giant there's testosterone in
our semen
i have no idea it doesn't taste like it
[Laughter]
right
i read a study where sex increases
testosterone
the hormone because having sex but then
i don't know if masturbation activates
the same thing as having sex because
when you're with a woman or like you
know you're just [ __ ]
and you know let's not be gender biased
so so would it just be in our minds what
if
gay sex actually
boosted higher tissue it does let me
tell you it does
it does dude at the same time how do you
think [ __ ] look double testosterone
i don't know what i'm doing i never even
well maybe they need to do this study
but they did the yeah dude i bet if you
jack off like three times a day that's
like no effect but you do seven you
probably get some effect that's not an
effect on your body some way yeah seven
times or not i think you do seven times
of anything a day seven times
you know how many naps i'm gonna be at
dude that's like to me that's like high
school jack off time this guy is are you
alone that many times like
he's probably doing it in public yeah
maybe he doesn't have to be alone he's
with his coaches and they're talking
about the game plan he's just jacking
off he's like sorry by the fifth time
i'm just busting dust you know
aren't you so tired you can't jump rope
anymore too
his legs are weird there's no way you're
jump roping after seven times he doesn't
look like a guy who jump ropes he
doesn't he doesn't look like he just all
boxes jump rope he's light on his feet
dude he's a big boy i think it must be
one of those things where six times and
you're [ __ ] tired but the seventh
time you unlock a special thing yeah and
it just like
you think it's like uh like uh the
runner's high you know what i'm talking
about or it's like seconds or something
once you get to a certain level it's
like you run like two three miles you're
like really tired you're on like five
six miles suddenly you have runners
hiding so it's a battle of grit every
day he doesn't want to jack off seven
times a day but he knows he has to do it
yeah that's what it is but doesn't i
thought everyone could sleepy
you do but in the second time that's
when you get the globe that's when
you're this tier you know what i mean
but when you're tyson fury you know you
got to reach an upper echelon of
masturbation level because i remember
maybe we should try this seven times
thing is that is that championship level
maybe it's seven masturbation is that
what that is do you think all of our
athletes are championships i'm gonna
google that yeah look that up i don't
know
his routine
i want to know how what he like does
what he watches what do you like
right-handed
jerk off
he literally told you he doesn't even
box
masturbations in japan
is it yeah so it's a real thing
championship for that maybe it's like
who jacks off the most or whatever i
mean it better be that what else i don't
want to go there sorry all right anyways
he says tyson fury says got to keep that
blood pumping baby the only thing i have
been loading is testosterone from all
the winning over the years right hands
and left hands depending on what i feel
like that's pretty tight that's pretty
much
i
dexter
dude he's trolling it's funny give me a
break he's throwing it he's getting
clicks for the fight come on um i'm sure
he's trolling but at the same time yeah
that could be yeah he could do this
this is the first time that fury has
claimed that having a a wink has helped
him at his craft so i mean it must be a
consistent joke do you think he's trying
to get into the mind of his opponent and
then they're like well if he does that
i'm gonna try that and then he's gonna
beat off yeah and then after we're not
when he's when he's fighting he's like
yo man that technique didn't work
my legs
do you think he's in the do you think
he's in the ring and he's like can't we
just jack off that's why that's what
i've been doing what have you been doing
oh let's talk about jacking off how
we're going to beat our dick that'd be
funny if his his boxing gloves is like
shaped to like hold a dick
up there's a hole like it's perfect so
that right between rounds he's like imma
get you man hold on
i can't wait till i start seeing pro fap
videos on youtube because you know like
there's no problem
that was now they're going to go through
this whole pro fab move that sounds like
a league
watch it becomes a league
knowing dudes they're probably going to
start breaking it down association pfa
pro flap association if they have like a
pillow fighting league like a legit
pillow fighting league they do have that
they're going to have a jack off league
too i think i think that's next do you
guys know about joi porn what's that
jackoff instructionals oh yeah when the
girl's going like this she goes yeah you
gotta go up and down so they're just
bossing you around they're telling you
how to jerky yeah they're just they're
basically just like it's like simon says
but yeah [ __ ]
shows around kids
i think
i take offense to jack off instructions
for kids to learn yeah i think i know
how to do this yeah yeah i got this
sweetheart thank you i mean i guess it
could be if you're [ __ ] that
irresponsible with a [ __ ] internet i
don't need a woman telling me how to
touch myself okay
you don't have a dick i do the video so
you just totally go against what they
say you just yell back out girl
that's not how it feels
yeah it's like internet trolls will do
they watch instruction video they're
like she obviously doesn't know she's
talking about
oh great
woman who doesn't have a penis tell us
how to use our penis
there should be more men's rights
activists in there talking [ __ ] to them
the problem is is that they they've come
already so they're more chill oh yeah
they're way more like yeah i think the
entire porn industry is a men's rights
activist
group
well no no the men's rights guys are the
guys who are like they're like
really
against jerking off because it like
ruined their lives or something
and and and women ruined their lives too
so like it's it's a bunch of things
working together
they're they're the ones fighting
against feminism should we get to ask an
expert of a men's right activity oh we
should dude and just ask them questions
just to be like what are you talking
about just put joe here
yeah it's a men's rights act they really
exist yeah yeah that's pretty heavy i
would put them up there with male
like i think what's worse what's worse
male feminism
because they're just doing it to get
late at least at least we know the men's
rights guys are never getting late and
they're getting zero positions dude i
actually saw
i saw a real
male feminist a i saw one
in the flesh guess out of all places
where [ __ ] hollywood
eating at a thai restaurant on a [ __ ]
date right next to me it was so good the
conversation was so [ __ ] good that i
couldn't even eat my meal i was just
laughing the whole time just pulled up a
chair next [ __ ] you were just
overhearing like what he was saying yeah
he was basically
talking [ __ ] about women while he was
talking good about them it was the most
bizarre [ __ ] he's all like well you know
how women are they're like this and this
and this but in my studies
you know like and then he would use that
[ __ ] buzzword my studies he's talking
about i think the future is female and
like you know obviously men have been in
charge for so long like it's time to be
emotional in government isn't it time to
be more emotional in government
spaghetti
he's eating a bag of dicks dude
[ __ ] that dude right out of the bag it
was so inauthentic like it was it was he
was just constantly using these
buzzwords to try to win her over and and
you know he's like this
pseudo-intellectual and he's also like
talking down at her like oh yeah you
know well from
you know with with my intellect and my
understanding of intellect
because you know i can psychoanalyze
myself and yeah this same age and it's
like [ __ ] for real
yeah he probably just slayed her that
night
hero [ __ ] bro this was his move no this
was this move now she was eating it up
because of the type of girl she was i
think she was the one
that wanted to believe this guy was real
she's a chelsea because she had rainbow
hair
she was she did have colored hair yeah
shocking she was one of those girls i
think that were like not interesting but
then like it's like they try to
be a part of that hollywood world to be
an artist but then like not really you
know what i mean like it's just the it's
just yeah the pretending of being an
actor but not really an actor yeah
meanwhile they're going home they're
like you see that [ __ ] asian guy with
longer students laughing by himself the
whole time what a [ __ ] weirdo eating
alone laughing by himself
[Laughter]
yeah the restaurant's a bag of dicks
everyone's eating bags here
so so this was
feminist night so this was his move he
paid for the meal right and he grabs her
hand and he goes you're damned if you do
and you've damned if you don't you know
when men pay for it it's like oh my god
they're the patriarchy
but uh
sometimes i just
i just i just feel like i gotta do it if
i don't do it then i'm i'm a loser i'm
broke or what if this is a tinder date
and then i'm just like
what if he's a tinder swindler why does
he have this why does he have to say
that just [ __ ] pay for it like a
normal human being because he knows
you're listening he wants to make you
laugh yeah
he's like this guy's listening to me
right now he's a big fan
did this chick say anything or is this
guy like [ __ ] psychoanalyzing all his
[ __ ] she basically he basically talked
over her the whole time yeah this guy is
dope she should be here minions too i
was just like oh yeah that makes sense i
was like listening and you know like
sometimes when you're listening you're
also responding in your head and you're
not
saying her points and i was like oh yes
yeah that makes sense yeah
you might hear me
[ __ ]
like tom yum shrimp you know what i mean
with crispy rice yeah i'm hungry now
yeah yeah dude [ __ ]
i'm so convinced the guy was joe
yeah that's pretty good joe's just
talking to hannah
[Music]